my advice to guys is you are likely not
going to find a healthy relationship in
a big city just going to like normal
Hangouts where people your age go
because Millennial women are like 78
Democrat overwhelmingly so you're going
to find whatever this person's views are
tremendous social pressure in their
circles to reject whatever it is you
might want to bring to the table so uh
the simple way to put it is you might
meet a woman who she's very much like
want to have a family and have kids and
then you're like this is someone I can
date and then every person they know and
every social media account and everyone
who follows them and they follow is
screaming be a CEO and don't have kids
and so they're being pushed in both
directions yeah and look I I will say
because I didn't mean to like rip on
those guys that much I just think it's
like silly to like be debating with
these like young chicks or whatever but
look I like I do think there is some
there's a reason they exist they're like
a necessary pushback the insanity the
dating feminism yeah